hi guys i'm hayley Seif Eldin I am going
to be answering some fan questions with
these adorable puppies a cute little
baby
[Music]
um I love the idea of playing a young
yes they agree they already they've
heard this answer quite a few times um a
young female character who is just this
normal girl but is brave and strong and
smart and just capable of the world this
film has a lot in it a lot that I think
transformers fans of the previous films
will enjoy and love and appreciate this
film has so much heart so much love and
laughter and it's very character-driven
it's got a lot in it that I think you'll
like
I would transform into a puppy so that I
could be a part of this this
so a full album I actually had every
intention on putting it up not this year
but this movie from belief sort of came
into the picture and a show called
Dickinson that I'm currently working on
and we'll be finishing up in the new
year and once that's done ow
I will be finishing what I started on
the music front so it's all in the works
and I can't wait to can't wait to tell
you oh it depends depends on what the
song is about who it's about I have uh I
have a handful of my closest friends
that I'll play my songs for and of
course my parents kind of sense so I've
been listening to a wide variety music I
feel like I always am with bumblebee the
film takes place in the 80s and has an
incredible eighties soundtrack so I've
got to immerse myself in that world of
music for a while one second please
and I love pop music so I listen to pop
music every single day and currently
Christmas music duh I feel like Dan
Keaton came to mind but Zach
Galifianakis also came to my dream music
collaboration um he's not gonna think
I'm serious but it's it's the truth
Benny Blanco or Fanny barranco if you
will whoa Emily junk she's worth giving
a call right finding out where she is um
Emily junk I would assume she is like
the head of a new social club
I'm sure she's doing a lot of writing
probably just living life to the fullest
probably hasn't stopped smiling since we
gonna saw her I would absolutely return
for his perfect for I know that when we
were doing the third one we spoke about
you know where the heck would we go from
here maybe space maybe we're all friends
by the next pitch perfect who knows but
yes I would love to be a part of it
Esther Dean Cynthia Rose she never fails
to make me laugh and think she could
figure out some way to get us off
[Music]
under eye concealer life's game changing
life changing a holiday tradition
honestly for me a holidays are all about
being with family and eating a ton of
food the last couple of years I've been
on the road so we've created new
traditions in the last couple of years
just because you know wife life holds
different things for age each year so
I'm just being with my family having a
little bit of time off and lots of food
is involved always 2019 well there is so
much in store for 2019 I am very excited
about my music that has been in the
works like I said for a while and a long
time coming so looking forward to to
that I can't wait for fans to see this
movie I that's at the end of this year
but we'll see where where that leads us
into the next year but music travel fans
performing all that I am very much
looking forward to 2019 these tiny
little babies were provided by Pacific
pups rescue and for more information you
can go to Pacific pups rescued calm
[Music]